Oh everyone I'm Jonathan I I thought I
would present something that's related
to my work I work with a small data
science consultant on C we did a bunch
of work with insurers and we do a lot of
work with smallish data so hierarchical
methods and Bayesian methods are are
interesting to us I put this talk
together like her doing many talks as a
method of basically learning it myself
so I'm far from an expert in using climb
C 3 for a couple of years but PI Stan
I'm quite fresh in I thought it was
quite interesting to perhaps compare
contrast and talk about them so it's
three things I want to do it's gonna
take possibly way more than 30 minutes
possibly not but all of this is actually
up on github as well I want to follow on
from Tom's fantastic intro to
probabilistic programming there isn't
and get up just share a little more
thoughts on on base and inference show
you a few of the capabilities and talk
about prime c3 and Dan hi Stan and
possibly think about getting involved so
we've seen some great stuff already
based on inference tells us more about
the why and how you know how these out
lie is different some stuff that I did
as a random task for Ian the other day
when he was talking about his sneeze
statistics was to try a Bayesian press1
regression to see if I could determine
if alcohol affected sneezing that's the
kind of stuff you might get into as the
changes in conversion rates and what
we're talking about today just a little
bit and apologies for the size of these
there bit small can we create a linear
model and determine whether cars from a
certain manufacturer are more or less
emitting and maybe we can discover if
you know Fox we're going to miss
misbehaving
I think Mitsubishi now as well which
actually comes up in the data you'll see
that a bit everyone draws this this is
my version traditional stats white box
modeling looking at stuff that you could
do in Excel or on paper towards one end
black box modeling where highly complex
computation at the other
and and you don't really care so much
about how the model is is is is what's
actually going on inside you just care
about that the test results I see the
the Bayesian inferential work that we
can do sitting somewhere in between
because like Tom said you're able to
introspect into the actual model
construction and create your version of
the world and the way that you think it
works and then press a magic button and
allow some black box sampling or
variational inference compute for you
the probabilities that you're after so
two options that we have in Python
frame-up pie MC and Stan Stan is
supported newly Bynum focus quite keen
for me to say that Y MC 3 doesn't have a
logo but it's made one sorry Tom I don't
use this it's terrible but I I thought I
thought I should show something both of
whom let us do some MCMC sampling and
there's some convenience functions there
hi Stan and Stan are effectively one in
the same hi Stan is is a thin wrapper
around Stan it doesn't do a whole lot
itself it does a couple of things that
are very useful but generally when I say
pie Stan I mean Stan when I say Stan I
mean by Stan something uh five minutes
in jump straight to the conclusion which
should I use I want to do some Bayesian
modeling what should I use it
what should I do I suggest apologies for
the formatting on this that prime c3 is
fantastic for rapid prototyping
everything's in Python there's no
messing about compiling anything else
everything's on your system everything
works and sorry Tom if this is going in
saying entirely the wrong thing but
there's a bunch of really great features
for for plotting putting arbitrary
functions in there so creating your own
likelihood functions tying in different
external samplers I foolishly tried to
use the MC sampler big ensemble sampler
we
i MC 3 about coming up two years ago now
and it worked which was great quite
scary that's that's a big old an
ensemble sample a very different kind of
concept where many many samples are
taken at the time and they aggregate
together to map how that posterior
probability function and arrive at the
answer in a much quicker time and it's
not a Markov chain so it doesn't you
don't have to worry about them getting
lost
if samples get lost in some well of
probability fine don't care about them
you've got tens of thousands or more and
that's there's some really cool stuff
out from Dan Forman monkey out of New
York it also has some nice things for
information criterion calculations leave
one out cross Val posterior predictive
checks post modeling so you can throw in
new data and you can do stuff like Tom
just showed with using Theano shared
variables to swap data around so it's
kind of fun on the other hand Stan PI
Stan and I say this has a relative
newbie to this using stan has all the
cool toys the sampling and the inference
and so on and it does have huge a
academic support and also it's supported
by an unfocused so has some some some it
has a nice logo it seems a little bit
more robust I would feel more confident
pointing at it with its static typed
language and so on if someone was giving
me a hard time about why a likelihood
was with a certain way around or certain
certain probabilities been pulled from
it so probably start off with PI MC 3
certainly myself and more familiar with
it it's it's a lot more simple to to
pick things out and the code is a lot
friendlier and more pythonic and
possibly stand things when you wanted to
make something a bit more
production-ready
possibly and run models and we'll see a
bit later about the type of relative
timing of these to their long story
short that they're similar enough on my
machine
both are open-source projects you can
contribute to them by mc3 actually has
quite a lot of stuff going on you know
50 odd contributors 4000 commits that's
pretty great one or two are from me most
different I'm and and the other guys and
standing is a bit more mature also
something with Stan is this this choice
between PI Stan and PI MC 3 doesn't
really exist in the our world where
everyone seems to be more or less
converging on Stan so if you've got
their two scientists split down the
middle between R and Python well this
crowd and then the Bayesian methods
probably using Stan so there is good
momentum behind out there there's a
bunch of existing comparisons Jake
vanden plas and Chris Burns from a
couple years ago there's some stuff that
I saw happened around the end of last
year released on Android government's
blog and some chap I don't know Isaac
slavit did another direct comparison of
primacy 3 and PI stands by the way this
is all up on github so you can turn off
the take notes there's also this yes
thank you so number 3 was get involved
there's loads of growing momentum in
this Stan pie Stan you can contribute to
Primus III as well MCMC plot live i'm
calling out because I quite like
plotting stuff and I have it on the back
burner tasks to start contributing to
that a little bit more which is some
nicer graphing and plotting for
probabilistic distributions and and and
really interpreting the models in a
graphical way there's a project in are
called shiny Stan which does this and it
does it very well actually and it's it
almost makes me want to pick up our
again but no you could you could read
more stuff from these guys there's a
longer reading list on a blog post that
I made you could throw in a meetup group
Big O London based in networks London or
- they're definitely knew this stuff
there's anyone in tum called Bayesian
mixer which i co-organized and we've had
two meetings so far third one is
scheduled for mid-june
it's talking about stuff a bit like this
and
examples work examples in industry
academia and the thing that's
interesting basically trying to just
gather a bunch of nerds in a room a bit
like this and yeah next one's in June so
okay I'll get on with it right so what's
that what I want to do what do I want to
do today um I was actually faster than I
thought it's good I will look at some
car emissions data it looks a bit like
this after cleaning in fact if I turn
around the other way
transpose this and add some information
you don't really have to know too much
about this but there's just over two
thousand two and a half thousand cars in
this car emissions data set they have a
bunch of I'm in the way onto that they
have a bunch of features the
manufacturer in the brand the the model
basically a loose description of it the
fuel that it takes some measurements of
its fuel performance some measurement
some categoricals on the transmission
and whether it's a turbo diesel and and
and the parent owner can ownership
company there's also a couple of things
on the emissions measurements and what
I've just plucked out of the air is I'm
going to try to predict the emissions of
nitrous oxide NOx non nice gas no one
really wants it if this is the thing
that caught out Volkswagen if you've
definitely familiar with the story but
they and I think Mitsubishi as well
basically faked their test results so I
wonder if we can perhaps determine that
from something in in the data
maybe we can regress very simple linear
regression on this value for any works
and holding all the other things
constant perhaps the fact that it's a
manufacturer X or Y has some impact some
bearing handful of distributions on
there this is talking about what I was
meaning we have the emissions and we
have a bunch of things that I'm going to
use to try to predict this transmission
fuel type engine size other measurements
of how efficient
the data set is reasonably balanced but
not massively so I'm concentrating on VW
again so the actual manufacturer of VW
is it's very few of those most cars are
not from VW but when you look at the
parent company actually quite a chunk
are because they are now D and a bunch
of others and what a fuel type I'm gonna
ignore hybrids widget in petrol versus
diesel transmission flappy paddles or
manual or auto that it's it's moderately
well balanced it's not perfect the
categoricals are kind of interesting as
for actual you probably can't see half
of this but four actually what's their
most parent so most cars the brand the
manufacturer is is BMW saudis mercedes
ford mini and so on volkswagen is
actually about number six just here
however again when we look at the parent
size BMW in volkswagen not half are by
my father the largest actually the cross
plot of those again this is way too much
it's all on line is that we have let's
say volkswagen owning OD bentley
lamborghini Porsche se and Skoda and
Volkswagen as well so there's a whole
load of brands underneath the umbrella
on the other hand there's some things a
bit like Mitsubishi which only makes
Mitsubishi branded cars so you can see
here it might be interesting if we're
looking at at the manufacturer these
these ones to have some measure of the
parent in there so there is an inherent
hierarchical structure in here I don't
want to say if your car is you know an
Audi that's all I care about
I might as well care about the fact that
it's made by a parent company so numeric
features they look broadly ok this is a
thing to try to predict it's it's not
pathological there's a few outliers
we're going to get rid of those engine
capacity seems a little bit
groups perhaps I was worried about that
the point to be showing you this it's
showed that the data is not perfect it's
real and it's a mess and there's real
problems some of these features that I
could choose from the metric combined
are highly correlated so our perhaps try
to choose just one or two of those and
in the repo I think I go through a
constrained lasso regression to try to
drop out these features I'll go through
this just quickly looking at the
categoricals versus the emissions knocks
again that they they look reasonably
well distributed there are things like
if you are a diesel car you probably
have higher emissions in in an O X
that's just the way the engine works
that's that that's that's fine that's a
detail oh yeah
just you just out of respect for your
eyes I won't show this too much but when
you look at the actual cars and the car
emissions you get you get a picture of
roughly where you expect the cars to
behave as far as their emissions go out
OD for instance are very narrowly
bunched whereas that same mercedes-benz
have some cars which are branded
mercedes-benz which have quite a range
of our emissions you know McLaren are
there with just a single dot in the
middle you can look into all of this the
distribution of numeric feet it's they
correlate a little bit there's gonna be
something in there just having a look at
a t sneer app of this as well just to
get an impression of how distributed the
the predictor variables are in terms of
the whole the whole the whole data
points you can see that there are there
are some hotspots in here you familiar
enough with Tizen e representations
squishing down many dimensions into two
and then being able to plot that so
points that are far away in high
dimensional space are still far away in
this yeah it's kind of a clustering in
points that are close together in high
dimensional space are close together on
this so we see there are bunches of cars
each dot is a car
which have a high metric of extra-urban
there are similarly some which have a
high engine capacity and if you look at
things like the manufacturers VW there
are cars which are VW around about here
in the input vector space so they're a
little bit clustered maybe something
maybe this is model Abel it's not
completely heterogeneous probably a
linear model is wrong but let's find out
okay so I'll leave the data I've cleaned
it I have divided it by two standard
deviations as Galman suggests is a good
idea it puts your numeric features into
the same same same variance as
categoricals binaries describe them they
said skip over that right these are the
features that I want to use in my model
that's what I'm trying to predict that's
what's going in
that's the roughly the data type that I
got so I've got some some factors
boolean and some some floats and int and
there so it's a mixed bag I've got
twenty parent companies and thirty-eight
manufacturers so this is how my how I
can state using a patsy kind of syntax
my my model so my linear model for it
starts at least in the pooled model is
emissions are something to do with the
fuel type transmission whether it's
turbo diesel engine capacity the
combined performance and the emissions
of carbon dioxide carbon ox come on okay
all right so a pull model called linear
model I state boldly that formula we
just saw that explains my my emissions
it's actually much less interesting than
Dan Foreman mark I has very recently
created this daft library which lets you
create plates and notation so I'll show
a bit more of these as we go on because
what we're going to do is start making
this more and more complicated as it
gets more hierarchical so what this is
saying is take all the features that
we've got there's a coefficient on each
standard linear regression that's
describing the mean of a normal
distribution from which I pluck the
emissions value and thus this is saying
exactly the same thing I observe the
emissions value it's determined by this
this dot product of the coefficients and
the data the coefficients come from
their shared they come from some
external single value across all cars
for let's say the parameter on if it's
turbo diesel and there's a noise factor
in here as well nice time it's a prime
c3 looks a bit like this I'm warming
into this because later chunks of code
though show are messy because I've done
some timing in there as well this is the
general gist now I think things as yours
time wrote a small module which takes
the Patsey string takes that takes that
model specification and creates the
priors and the likelihoods for you
within the model which is a nice lazy
way very convenient way I was specifying
the model so let us say this is with my
little that's knob jet in this context
make something from from here here's my
data set and this is the likelihood
function I think it will be and you go
off and prime c3 and do the rest I'm
using a student T distribution here
again to try to cope with outliers it's
got fat tails this is actually how the
rest of my code looks which is a bit of
a mess but you'll recognize this bit
and two bits where I am trying to make a
best guess of where to start
I'm far from an expert in why this takes
forever but it's an optimization
technique to try to find the max a
posterior a point to which to start the
sampler off it's not sometimes that
works sometimes it gets stuck forever so
there's other better ways of doing it
including possibly the variational
inference right this bit is instructing
it to take some samples I'm going to
take four thousand samples because that
seems like a reasonable amount you can
use the nut sampler I'm requesting it in
this case and there's only one only case
that's a 2 2 to run on one core and to
not multi-process the reason for that is
because I tried running it on 2 and it
didn't work
yeah prime c3 is a bit a little bit in
beta still and occasionally stuff goes
wrong and you're not quite sure of where
it is possibly the multi processing or
in speaking to to piano and scheduling
jobs so most the time it works but
occasionally it doesn't it's quite
interesting to see when it doesn't I
don't mean that in a bad so right I can
run the model I can take my traces these
are the final thousand traces these are
the density distributions of those those
those parameters this is a marginalized
posterior probability of the intercept
the values for petrol manual whether
it's semi-auto Toa diesel engine
capacity and so on so these are the if I
want to recreate my my emissions this is
a linear model you've seen this before
so I just if I want to have to take the
the max value all of these multiply that
by the values for each car and I should
arrive at roughly the the emissions
value and the nice bit is I think I've
done this know you can see where I was
making stuff up as I go on nice thing is
these are real distributions as time
mentioned we have a credible region
around around each value and we can we
can compute various nice things the
posterior probability of
the final results and look even at each
each coefficient to try to gauge how
tightly bound it is and get to get a
much better picture of what's actually
going on so the stun model looks a bit
different not in a bad way but it's a
it's a um this like way definite here is
is it the the Stan proprietary custom I
guess syntax which compiles down to C++
it looks a bit like C or C++ anyhow the
model is is is this string and what Pye
Stein will do for us nicely is take the
string and go away and compile C++ which
we can then run it's it's a nice thin
layer over the top of things so we're
able to declare the data going in there
the parameters so well the data going in
is that you know here you see it count
the observations count the exact
features the raw data going in and the
predicted feature that I'm trying to get
out the parameters within the model are
this this this set of coefficients this
long is this wide vector the model error
transform parameters is an option I
haven't used it here haven't needed to
and then we just describe the model so
it looks quite similar again here's our
noise is being pulled from a Cauchy
distribution it's actually being pulled
from a half Cauchy distribution because
I've declared a lower bound on it so you
see that's the the prime c3 way of doing
that would be to declare an actual
halfcourt redistribution this one is is
inferred and then I'm pulling the
results from a cross of coefficients
from a student T distribution with some
error that we've seen it's fairly
straightforward generated quantities
down here is for things like posterior
predictive checks and that goes about
something I mentioned before which is
that it's it's possible to do PPC using
pi mc3 post modeling but
but withstand it seems to be they have
to do it during the model so we feed it
a dictionary of some of the values run
it using something a little bit a bit
like this and looks it looks reasonably
similar I'm telling it here's my here's
my code string my data is in that
dictionary that I put together I'd like
a thousand iterations burn the first
three quarters of them and run run four
chains on two jobs so it's quite
flexible quite quite possible to specify
where they want it multi-core how many
chains you want usually more better
because then they don't necessarily get
stuck in in Wells and off you go the
results summaries that come out of it
aren't especially pretty but they're
quite they're a good first step for
Diagnostics so we get an impression of
what the mean is for our parameters
coming out and and the distributions of
them can also plot these and that's more
or less as far as i i've seen where pi
the niceties of pi stand pretty much end
after that you're on your own you have
to do your own plotting more or less so
now yes i won't take too long going
through these we've seen the on the
pulled model which ignores the
manufacturer clearly that's no good if
we want to call out which manufacturers
is more omitting the unpooled model this
is one version of that where I put the
manufacturer value on to the intercept
there's also a nun pulled a fully kind
of important where every manufacturer
gets their own entire model which is
just basically the same as dividing up
the dataset completely into the 38
manufacturers and doing thirty eight
separate regressions which again is
fairly pointless so yes this looks a bit
like that so so with the I should
probably put these on a separate thing
but anyhow what you see here is another
plate so this inner plate is per car the
outer plate is per manufacturer so now
I'm pulling this intercept from the
manufacturer itself in prime c3 it
doesn't look a whole lot different I'm
now declaring my full model I'm
no longer using Tom's gln thing I'm
actually declaring each prior that's
going in there and declared my model and
well you've seen this bit anyway it's
fallen off yet but the key bit is its
vectorized this beta0 this this
manufacturer that I'm using for the
intercept is now vectorized as this is a
38 long Theano object and that's
basically all you have to do to make
this M prime c3 model unput which is
really nice we can run it we can see
some traces on the default plotting this
is more SD for plotting everything
appears on the same plane things so it's
a bit messy but it's it's a nice check
to see what's going on país done in
contrast I can still for this one use a
vectorized form I've got an encoding
here on the manufacturer and that's
going in to this extra beta 0 which I'm
also declaring here
so the vectorization bit in pice 10 or
so in stan is similar up to a point and
we can run that and compute a fit great
the first thing that comes up now we can
know that we have evaluations on the
manufacturers is estimations yeah
estimations of the effect of that
manufacturer on the emission and this is
it's a robust regression but it's still
a linear linear regression it's fairly
done every manufacturer is free to float
every value can free float and what we
see is things like this is the count of
obviously the cars as well so we see
most of always is cars which are brands
which are present in many instances tend
to have more narrowly defined credible
regions this is the mean value by the
way cars which are underrepresented tend
to have quite wide estimates of the
value you know there's only two Ferraris
in the group and the estimate of
the the coefficient value has quite a
wide bound not especially helpful
digress past they are fully on pole
model it turns into a mess gets very
pretty plots though if you like colors
so a partially pulled model I'll save
you the rest of the stuff this this is
the the the plate diagram again again
every manufacturer gets their own beta
coefficient their own intercept but this
time we're putting a hierarchy on that
and saying that they come from two
shared parameters which are higher up so
this is the partial pooling this is
saying if you have a value here it
depends on a little bit upon the
distributions that are finding it
outside which are shared by all cars so
in this way we end up with we end up
sharing power across the model in prime
c3 that looks again still quite nice we
just declare that the the mean and
standard deviation of this prior have
come from something else and we declare
that something else above it and that's
pretty much it
quite quite compact we run that we find
some stuff yep I know this focus too
much on the actual outputs of this in PI
Stan it looks a little bit similar but
it's fallen off the bottom but you can
just about see here I've had to start
doing some looping because the
vectorization is not always quite clear
and this one was just about doable but
what I'm about to show you next
caused me to bang my head on the desk
for a number of days trying to figure
out how Stan decides that it wants to
work in the partial pooling I've
declared that the PI Stan and and and
prime c3 performed pretty much the same
great and here we can see the effect of
that shrinkage on the partial pooling so
now every every car also pulls its
distribution from some shared hyper
parameter and you can see the effect
that it has on under-represented cars
like Mitsubishi
Ferrari Lamborghini and so on which
previously had wide and god-knows-where
estimates they've now been pulled in a
little bit more it seems a little bit
more robust it seems more reasonable
so can we comment on Volkswagen yeah a
little bit I'll go back just a tiny
second it seems Volkswagen is here it
seems to have a fairly tight
distribution and it seems to be higher
than around average
so maybe but there's there's other
offenders Mitsubishi Subaru McLaren seem
to have far higher emissions and again
there's no way of determining who's
lying in this but it's an interesting
kind of way to get into it
finally a hierarchical model gets a
little bit more complicated now I'm
taking them out the parent into account
so again I've grown this or growing this
ago in this now I'm saying suggesting
that this intercept on the manufacturer
is not shared amongst all cars but it
actually depends upon the parent and
those are shared and this finally lets
us get to our understanding of the real
world and that model in pi MC 3 again
it's actually quite nice although it did
have to phone a friend for some help
with some of the indexing but
fundamentally you're still dealing with
vectors and it's still fairly
straightforward you run it you find some
distributions great with Pais tan and
this is fallen off the button so I
apologize you'll have to look at the
actual code yourselves it turned into
more of an indexing problem and this
really was a bit of a bang head-on the
best thing so again that goes back to me
thinking that prime c3 is great for
tight testing stuff out Stan is where
you want you have the time to sit down
and really consider stuff what does this
lead to
in the end some trace plots oh ok a
slight diversion on to model one times
they're approximately similar the stand
model was way faster at competing the
pool the model this is for a similar
number of counts by the way similar
accounts of samples not sure why primacy
was a bit longer here I think it was in
the model compilation phase but
otherwise they track similarly it
certainly wasn't huge
noticable and a huge pain to use one or
the other I know that now this was
timing the model build and the model
running steps and it seems that Stan
once the model is built is actually
extremely quick so if you again if you
want to put something into production
possibly you want something that is pre
built and choose them again probably got
two more minutes I hope and we're taking
much longer this is the outputs from the
hierarchical model on the manufacturers
in C there's been a there's been a few
changes around there you know things
like smart the smart cars have been
pulled upwards they're part of Mercedes
group there's a few other changes in the
order it's it's hard to infer too much
from that but but now we can also look
at the parent group and see that as
parents we see that the McLaren are big
big emitters Shanghai Auto came from
nowhere
BMW milestone so and Volkswagen are not
that bad they're kind of mid pack if we
look at the XY in this which is not
necessarily true to do but I thought
this was interesting because you can see
the families of cars now so you can see
McLaren out by itself it's high it's got
a high coefficient value on up on here
Mitsubishi again very high anything
that's towards this end is is a highly
emitting car the families that we've got
are quite interesting
whereas okay here's the Volkswagen Group
is in orange here mid pack you've got
within the family within the parent
group we've got Volkswagen Bentley Audi
up towards the top coming down in
emissions towards CR Lamborghini Volvo
Skoda and Porsche at the bottom there so
if you're buying VW car by Porsche being
nice as the environment
and this is the kind of stuff that we're
able to do because we have a
hierarchical view of the real the real
bot for the real model and that's that
so thanks and everything's up here on
github if you want to go through it in
at your leisure right do you have time
for a question that's a very good
question yes what I didn't show you but
what is in here is it's possible to
calculate various information
Criterion's along the way and also do
posterior predictive checks to find out
how the model performs on held-out data
so we can do the same tricks as we do in
your regular machine learning and do
tests on on holdouts and
cross-validation and so on on this one I
didn't actually do it yet I did compute
the way at the wake
yes and I come back to me I will
actually commit that bit and put it up
here it's a good question
apocryphally I think it was the partial
poll that performed the best of all
what would I say I've no idea how to do
it in a frequentist modeling way it
seems horribly complicated to setup
mixture models it's there's there's a
again fork went astray this there's
loads of assumptions that aren't
necessarily true to your data I found
that in the Bayesian framework those
assumptions are made obvious and clear
and it's it's a lot more of a natural
way to do not really know in fact I was
able to use the nut samplers for
everything here and that's usually a
good bellwether at least in my
experience because we're not tends to
fail it's because something awful is
wrong with with some some gradient
somewhere in in your in your vector
space and it seemed to perform
yeah
distributed computing for the MC
sampling does I'm reliably informed yes
that's fine yes no problem at all um
that's an interesting one they as far as
I see not massively however I skipped
past a page plotting the autocorrelation
along the sample lense actually no so
both do both do so poem see three out of
the box lets you plot autocorrelation
which is a nice lagged way of seeing how
the samples correlate to throughout
throughout their own history down their
path and that's a nice out-of-the-box
way to test if your to correlation is
high well either something's
misspecified or you need to burn more it
doesn't as far as I know have a measure
of our hat which I know Stan kicks out
which is another measure of
autocorrelation which you get basically
for free in those printed summaries and
again it's it's it's a it's a kind of
rule of thumb if it's our hat value is
bigger than one point one then again
you're over correlated so that there is
stuff there actually straight away but
it's it's fine-tuning finessing and
everything okay
you